constellation starship
frontier we have you on scanners
[Music]
performing remote systems
we are still going
they say the wonder is not that the
field of stars
is so vast but that we have measured it
you're part of constellation now part
of our family what you found
it's the key to unlocking everything
[Music]
we reach this is all we've been working
towards
looks good we've come to the beginning
of humanity's final journey prepare for
[Music]
departure
[Music]
to discover what's out there
[Music]
incoming fire
attention all squads the russian troops
are falling back
do whatever you can to secure the
sectors
[Applause]
we push them back but not far enough do
not let them regroup
[Music]
down
uh
what job
hey
[Music]
[Music]
so
a new day is upon us a new
generation built to fight
together we are unstoppable
are you ready
no scope
hello let's do some damage
skewer acquired
return it to base
ordinance drop inbound
the flag is ours
please call us at your earliest
convenience
now show me what you can do
[Music]
these things where do they come from
from all of us from what we do to him
can you stop it i don't know
but he's my brother and i would die for
[Music]
him
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
i recognize that voice let me ask you a
question
when i am dead and yellow is burning
what exactly is your plan hold hands
sing songs around the fire sure
i know just this song
[Music]
[Music]
a stealth operation i got you covered
taking out a high-value target i have
just what you need
[Music]
you want to blow [ __ ] up juan cortese at
your service
[Music]
wait a second who brought the rooster
hey whatever you need to get the job
done danny
next time i see you i want to play with
that crazy backpack
[Music]
so do i
evil has survived
the dark figure wanders in the east
he must be stopped
at all costs
[Music]
fear me
[Music]
this may be our darkest hour
but it will be your greatest moment
[Music]
uh
an eel wind blows from beyond the
horizon
a new danger is coming on the tides
and the one who might stop this ruin
trapped for all forever in the sea of
the damned
now to save the pirate life
you must start by saving the life of
one
oh didn't realize we had company
captain jack sparrow
but i suspect you already knew that
because of the treasure jack storm a
darkness
followed in here and if it's not stopped
this world will sink into
shadow this sea holds many
secrets ah a new body of lies
all i can do is show you knowing from
what i hear of this so-called sea of
thieves
it's nothing but cursed crew
bloodthirsty mermaids
a legion of dead angry pirates
oh yes and now on davey jones
well i believe that now is the perfect
time to use these cannons
a world without the enterprise
is a world that refuses to face the
truth
nothing lasts forever destroy that
i don't suppose by chance there's a
second one of those
the sea of thieves i bring me that
horizon
[Music]
[Laughter]
is
[Music]
so
[Music]
mm
[Music]
video
[Music]
diamonds
[Music]
oh
[Music]
dude
my
yes
[Music]
foreign
stalker
we begin by hearing an old wise sounding
voice
when we see a quiet peaceful setting
this will make our game seem big and
important
now something must break the serenity
will this creature be in the game
now say goodbye to it forever
suddenly and for no reason people
running these pointless slow motion
shots
make everything seem cool and should
bolster pre-sale numbers
that war sound can mean only one thing
we must gaze over an epic shot of a
world
and there should be lens flares
now we see our hero
but only their silhouette because the
developers haven't finished the design
or finished the story or finished any
gameplay
that's actually ready to show in fact
the only thing they have finished
is the title
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna have to take you apart again
hey dove
anything interesting it's exist too
25 centimeters dramatically elongated
go on make yourself useful
so uh that was fun right
[Music]
that's your queue mate
[Music]
you think they can't kill you anytime
they want
hey [ __ ]
how do we always get into this
massachusetts behind me we are
witnessing clear signs
of cult activity as the locals engaged
hey
i really hope the video was worth it
everybody
fall back people need to know what
happened
thank you laila you're the best oh jacob
don't even mention it
[Music]
where's the other one where'd it go
give me your chilis
oh [ __ ] dev's gonna love this one
you better have a plan jacob yep
don't miss
don't trust
kill me and me you can't break the
bloody trends
i think there's vampire in this really
what does it taste like be specific like
blood and
death and strawberry sun's coming up
let's keep moving let's keep moving
sure thing edgar allen bro that's a good
one
do you think things will ever go back to
normal
would you want to go back to normal not
if i still have to pay my student loans
[Music]
[Music]
you